so this is usually the bit where I take
a bunch of stuff out of the locker and
there's like a really cool Montage but I
have nothing to take out because we're
talking about Game Pass which is
entirely digital
and also it has been around for six
years
it is the service that has become
synonymous with the phrase the greatest
deal in gaming and rightfully so it has
had a tremendous impact on the way many
of us play games
me included no really it has
it has changed me over the years of
being a Game Pass subscriber my
relationship with games how I buy them
play them and what console I choose to
play them on has been dramatically
altered
honestly it's kind of debatable whether
or not that's a good or bad thing
because I think it's a little bit of
both in fact the whole thing has got me
asking is Game Pass changing how I or
how we all value games
when I take a step back and reflect on
the past six years my thoughts are
usually always it's been great I've
never been this versed in games before I
get to try things I otherwise wouldn't
and yada yada yada and that is all true
but there's another side to this and no
two games better illustrate my
relationship with Game Pass than
ghostwire Tokyo and Hi-Fi rush and by
the way both of those games are actually
by the exact same developer Tango
Gameworks which is completely
coincidental really let's start with
ghostwire Tokyo when ghostwire Tokyo was
revealed it was showcased as a
PlayStation exclusive they had the devs
Behind The Evil Within it was a new IP
it was spooky paranormal and Fantastical
it seemed by all accounts like a Kurt
game however around the same time it was
revealed Microsoft announced its
acquisition of Tango's parent company
Bethesda softworks which meant its days
as a PS5 exclusive or inevitably
numbered it was only a man out of time
until it made its way on to Game Pass so
despite my interest in the game I held
off I didn't buy it in the hopes that it
would eventually come to the
subscription service as a result a game
that I was actually pretty excited for
was shoved to the back of my mind until
a year later when it did indeed come to
Game Pass and oh yes that was a
pre-install all right now on the Hi-Fi
Rush
during an Xbox showcase earlier this
year Tango Gameworks revealed an all-new
hyper-stylized cartoonishly over-the-top
Rhythm action game it looked really cool
and then out of nowhere like a Nintendo
Direct mic drop we're happy to tell you
that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
that made it suddenly even cooler the
results swept through headlines and blew
up my Twitter feed and absolute slam
dunk of a surprise and yeah I instantly
installed it
here's the thing if Hi-Fi Rush had just
launched as a regular game at a regular
price without the support of Game Pass I
know I would have most likely passed on
it nothing against it like at all I just
know that if I had to vote with my
dollars I probably would have put those
dollars somewhere else maybe even
ghostwire Tokyo but because it launched
on Game Pass a service that I browse
almost every single day I had nothing to
lose but to give it a shot and you know
what
it's pretty good and you know what I
didn't think was very good ghostwire
Tokyo
about that sinking for a second
oh and also another important point that
involves both those games is that I
haven't finished either one of them
and I likely won't so what do I do with
this realization on one hand there was a
game I wanted waited and stalled it
played it for a few hours and decided it
wasn't for me but on the other hand was
a game I wouldn't have played but
because it was available to me I did and
end up enjoying it but I still did not
finish it when I realized this it had me
starting to look a little closer at my
overall habits with the greatest deal in
gaming some of my favorite games are on
Game Pass new and old ones some of which
are from a pre-game pass world Grim
Fandango Paradise killer 999 the Yakuza
series While others I got to play
because of Game Pass Norco immortality
hellblade gun grave Gore but the thing
is I realized while I was scrolling
through all the games on Game Pass
there's really only a handful and then
some that I've actually seen to the end
otherwise there is a graveyard of
Unfinished games on my hard drive
Proteus a scorn tunics signalus The
Pedestrian pentiment and of course Hi-Fi
rush and ghost wire Tokyo or how about
the games I installed and just haven't
even touched like Somerville Ninja
Gaiden and The Artful Escape yeah I
don't really feel great about it also I
realized that like half these games that
like I have installed or from Game Pass
aren't actually even on Game Pass
anymore that's how long it's
you need to get around to some of these
games are just completely abandon them
for you know reasons of course I'm a
strong believer in the mentality that if
you don't want to finish a book
then you shouldn't and similar to books
games require a little more engagement
from you compared to something say like
movies or TV shows and to me it becomes
more about your time and attention as
the measurement of value rather than the
actual dollar amount when I think about
my time with ghostwire Tokyo or even
HiFi Rush would I have spent more time
with them maybe even viewed them
differently if I had actually purchased
them I honestly don't know but it's
enough to unravel my entire perception
of why I buy and play what I do versus
what I don't oh and speaking of when I
actually do buy a game I'm most likely
buying it on Xbox because it has become
my primary console and I owe that to
Game Pass
which is actually maybe really the point
here if I'm measuring success in my time
then well Xbox has won it because
regardless of whether or not I'm playing
a game on Game Pass or not I'm still
turning my Xbox on every day more than
any of the other consoles which was not
the case a few years back in fact I made
an entire video about that and how my
perception of Microsoft has changed to
say the least I wasn't even an Xbox user
until Game Pass came along that's game
passes crowning achievement over the
past six years getting people to talk
about Xbox and spend time on its
consoles and in the process it has
raised the bar for what will motivate me
to actually spend money on a game it
makes me think about the games I haven't
played or have not bought in hopes that
they will come to a service like Game
Pass games like the Callisto protocol
foreign
like ghostwire Tokyo there's a lot going
for the cluster protocol that had me
interested I love survival horror it was
deemed as a dead space spiritual
successor despite Dead Space remake
releasing only a month later and yet I
wasn't entirely sold on it you might
assume that it's because of the review
scores but it wasn't I actually have an
entire video about that that you should
consider watching it was that it didn't
seem interesting or compelling enough it
just had me curious at best which to me
is the quintessential sign of a I'll
just wait for Game Pass sort of game
even just saying that makes it feel like
I'm devaluing the games that do launch
the game pass which is not the case at
all this is just how my brain works now
so much so that if the callista protocol
was on PlayStation's game catalog Sony's
answer to Game Pass then maybe just
maybe I'd actually consider subscribing
to a whole other service just to play it
and that in of itself is a mess-up
situation for me to unpack that I
wouldn't consider playing a game that I
was interested in unless it was a part
of a subscription service like Game Pass
I would rather pay 15 extra a month to
play a game that on paper takes all of
my boxes rather than just Fork up
seventy dollars for a game that I may
even potentially love I at least know
that I'm not the only one that shifted
in some sort of way because of Game Pass
after all PlayStation did make the game
catalog the exact same model as Game
Pass and has been using it as a means to
Showcase some cool games like Humanity
or even stray as Day One releases for
the service I Still Love Game Pass and
I'm still gonna use it as a means to
dabble and experiment and try things
because that is what I'm paying for one
way or another it demonstrates that we
are live living in a post game pass
world at the moment and I'm having a
hard time imagining a pivot back
you know what
I'm buying the cluster protocol
foreign
[Music]